hello guys my name is a channel and
welcome to episode 10 of the
serialization series so last time we
talked about arrays and we wrote out
50,000 random integers out into the
console in our ization format and we
implemented the array class and all that
stuff went well however one thing that I
mentioned at the end of the episode was
that it would be nice if we could print
this out into a file rather than into
the console it's a bit hard to read in
the console and we have to like format
it and it takes a while especially if
it's a lot if it's a large amount of
data because console printing of course
is very slow so let's quickly implement
a little method that will help us
actually write bytes to a file so I'll
say maybe save to file or something
we'll have the path of the file and we
will have a byte array with the actual
data I'm gonna write a buffered output
stream so stream equals new buffett
output stream new file output string and
just put the path control shift o to
imported that stuff and surround with
try-catch here and then I'll just do
stream drive data and streamed up close
and we should be done right that should
pretty much be it I'll just replace this
with an i/o exception to get rid of that
error and we should be fine ok cool so
that was easy so instead of doing this
now what we'll do is we will grab our
stream instead of print by it's right
we'll just do save to file the path
right now we we will just probably save
to let's see so what should our
rainclouds relation file be raincloud
dot or maybe our CD I don't know rain
cloud database that'll be kind of like
our database and then we'll I guess
we'll call it like test and then the
daughter of course will be the stream
all right so if I run this it should
just write everything out of file if we
refresh the binary thing we should see
that test our CD file in our working
directory and we should see a bunch of
binary data which is being interpreted
as text here so if we actually do open
up the
oops if we actually do open up the
location of this workspace which is
right here
binary will see that test ICD file we
can open it with something like sublime
text and that will kind of show
everything here here it is soap now and
you can see all that stuff but we can
actually do one better and we can use a
utility called ik h XD which is my
favorite kind of hex viewer right a more
binary viewer whatever you want to call
it really a hex editor is what they're
called basically this will just let us
kind of look at this stuff and
immediately translate it into strings
and just sort of it a bit better than
just looking at a through sublime there
are some plugins for sublime that will
actually enable you to edit it properly
and translate it into characters as well
but I still prefer using h XD another
thing that sublime tends to do I'm not
sure if all versions of sublime text do
this but a lot of them actually load in
the entire file into memory first and
then start kind of viewing it which just
means that if you've got like a hundred
megabyte file it will actually take like
a minute to load whereas hxhx say just
remembering it just Mary map's the file
and it can you can scrub through it
smoothly and it only kind of loads in at
the data that's actually being displayed
which is cool kind of like notepad plus
plus as well alright so anyway if we
drag if we just drag this in you can see
that we'll see all of our stuff here we
can see you can easily see where the
bytes are you can see that that's the
name of our database here or the name of
our array in this case it's just called
test and then we have a whole bunch of
data which are random integers right
cool so there we go just something that
we can use from now on to look at our
outputs cool so today we're going to the
big thing that we're going to talk about
today is the next container type which
is an object okay
and after that because you guys are
curious as to what's gonna be next we're
going to talk about actually
implementing something called a database
and if you go back to the first kind of
few episodes where I drew diagrams and
we talked about that stuff a database is
just something that contains multiple
objects right so the idea is that
objects are just things that contain
feels and arrays
that's pretty much it okay so think of
an object as literally a class in Java
for example that's kind of what this is
we have a class and we have members
inside that class and they could be
fields like an integer here or string
there all that stuff strings is actually
done that's something that we need to do
as well but it could be like a normal
field or it could be an array of data
right like a bunch of integers there or
something like that and objects contain
multiple fields and arrays so let's go
ahead and just create a class called
object now I'm afraid this is probably
gonna cut this is probably gonna
conflict with Java's objects class so
I'm actually gonna call it RC object is
to avoid any kind of confusion our safe
course stands for rain cloud I'll
probably prefix all these at the end as
well like them filled in the array will
be like ah C feels nasty all right in
fact we could probably do that right now
if you just head over to the file right
click here hit refactor and rename or
old shift are and then type in our stay
at the front hit enter it should rename
everything including the file name and
we'll do the same thing for field as
well so our C field okay and now we
shouldn't have any kind of conflicts
with anything and you can see in Maine
now they're kind of switched over okay
cool this'll just this is almost like
putting it inside a namespace I mean we
already kind of have namespaces with
packages but stuff like object which is
available in every namespace because
it's actually you know in the Java it's
in the java dot lang package which
automatically gets included everywhere
we can't really do much to not use that
that namespace okay cool so ask the
objects what are they going to contain
well it's going to be very similar to
what our C arrays have right in our c
arrays we have the container type we
have I'm just gonna copy basically all
of this we're gonna go back to our c
object and paste that in container type
will be set to object of course it's
gonna have a name it's going to it's not
going to have a type or account or data
well yeah it's not gonna have any of
that stuff right it's gonna have a name
lengthen your name let's talk about what
our c object actually does have there
the main thing that it has of course is
a list of both fields and arrays so I
like to put a fields first so we can
have something like
an ArrayList of fields alright and we'll
just import that till list and then I'll
duplicate that and have the same thing
for a raise
it's up to you as to how you specify it
I mean a lot of people like like having
them sorted so in other words maybe you
put you like when you add things to an
object you have them in a certain order
that you want to maintain I'm not one of
those people I don't really care about
ordering too much because each of these
will have a unique name anyway or at
least it should have a unique name and
we can definitely like verify that as
well but that's the idea right so we
have a bunch of fields then we have a
bunch of arrays how many fields and
arrays we have are dictated by the
actual are dictated by the actual size
of those lists right so we know how many
we have so if we look at what the byte
structure kind of looks like we're gonna
have a bite for the container type we're
gonna have a short for the name length
so we're up to three bytes we're gonna
have our name and then we're going to
have of course and like a field like
amount of fields right so we'll have
Allen like a number of or account for
the amount of fields that we have
followed by all of the fields and now
some like if we were really talking
about kind of high-performance and
optimization and stuff it's usually a
good idea to have a table at the
beginning of your database
which says where everything is so that
way we never have to loop through or
kind of read the entire file if we just
want to extract one field because think
about it this way right if we have a
giant database here right and we're
literally like 100 like 100 megabytes
for example think about how difficult it
is going to be for us to fully do
serialize that data right if we were
looking for a specific fear like a
specific object with a specific name and
in there we wanted a specific field and
that's all we wanted right it would be
an absolute nightmare okay because it
would mean that first of all after
loading that file into memory we would
have to basically deserialize the whole
file into this kind of structure and
then somehow iterate
through all the objects until we find
the one we're looking for and then go
into all the fields and look at what
field we're searching for and that's how
we get that field not good right instead
what you want to do is create a hash
table or something like that at the
beginning of the actual serial as at the
beginning of the actual um civilization
database which has like for example
object and then by offset and that way
you can actually just straightaway jump
to what you're looking for to to see to
see you know where that data is located
and you can immediately find what you're
looking for so that's something that we
might do in the future I don't really
see that being a problem for us ever I I
might just do it just for fun right and
just to teach you guys about how that
will actually work and like for
education purposes because it is a good
idea to do that but remember this is
primarily designed for networking so
we'll never be sending databases large
enough for that to become a problem but
if you are sir izing something like a
savegame out and even if it is several
megabytes and you just want to view
something it is a really nice
optimization strategy to just do
something like a little list a little
table at the beginning of your of your
sterilization format which says where
everything is it's like an index alright
like a table of contents it's the same
situation as that if you're reading a
large book and it's like a thousand
pages and you're looking for one
specific chapter how are you going to
find it right you're gonna have to look
through everything but if you've got a
table of contents at the beginning or
like an index at the end you can
immediately find which page number you
need to go to and then just go there
immediately okay so there's the same
principle here so we could do something
like that we're not going to right now
because I want to get again I want to
get the groundwork done for all of this
and have it working and then we'll talk
about optimization okay cool so
especially because this series really
was never about producing something
overly complicated I want to kind of get
the simple stuff done first and then if
we have time we'll talk about
optimization and more advanced kind of
things that we can do to to make this
better
ok so when we create an object really
all I care about is passing in a name I
mean the type of data that it has varies
of course because fields in arrays
really different in the sense that
fields have their own names and like we
can how fields of different types right
we could have a couple buy it fields we
could have a couple long fields a couple
integers a couple of floats doesn't
matter right we could have oldest
variety of data here so I'll see object
is going to set the name in the same way
that we set it for fields and stuff so
again for now I will copy and paste that
code and then what we'll do is just call
set name with name right and you can see
that's kind of what we are what we did
with our constructors for all of this
stuff right obviously in this case we
had to create one for each kind of type
of data so we couldn't we didn't really
use new in fact this should have a
private constructor like I'll see field
does which just means that we can and we
can instantiate this class anywhere
except for inside this class which is
perfect because that's the only place
where we actually calling you right but
the API for an object is gonna look
pretty similar so we have this massive
RC array right let's use that as one of
the things that we actually put into our
object so when we make an RC object and
I'll kind of start laying this down now
because um because we like there's like
I usually like laying down the usage of
a of a class that I'm writing so that I
know how I want to design the API so
we'll make this object and we'll call
this let's just call this entity right
and then I'll call this like random
numbers or something it can have spaces
by the way there's no reason why you
wouldn't want to have spaces but you
know we don't need them okay cool
so I usually want to do something like
object add array or something or push
array or you can call it whatever you
like so I'll add in that array let's
also create a field so I'll do maybe
something RC field field equals RC field
dot okay let's see what we want let's
create an integer that would be kind of
easier to read for us we'll call this
integer and we'll tie
then eight okay that'll be pretty
straightforward and then we'll add field
as well so I wanted to be able to do
object add field and then finally I want
to be able to write out the object right
so object gets sighs object get bytes
and then that's all we have to do really
cool so let's start implementing these
things will start with field because
that's kind of a car logical thing I
guess fields then arrays so add field is
gonna be pretty simple we're just gonna
literally do fields add field it's
actually all we have to do we'll talk
about some more complex things that we
can do it will not only complex but so I
raised on out all right but awesome some
more things that we can add here just to
make our lives easier for example we're
gonna need to get size obviously so
we've got two ways of maintaining this
yeah we could say for in I equals 0 or
in fact we can just use a for each loop
where we say for each field in our
fields we'll say in size equals 0 and
then size plus equals fields dot get
size right size actually shouldn't be 0
size should be 1 plus 2 plus aim dot
oops name dot length for now right
anyway we'll say size plus equals field
and then of course we could do the same
thing for our arrays and that's actually
not too bad right it's not the best
thing to do but we could definitely do
it and there we go so we have to loop
through everything and we have to
collect the size and that's fine and
then we can return that at the end
that's one option and there's nothing
wrong with that another way that we
could implement this though is actually
to keep track of something called size
right and we'll sell this off with zero
we'll start this off with one plus two
plus we can't really don't actually know
the name length yet which is a little
bit unfortunate but we can start this
off with one plus two right and then of
course add when we set the name and when
we actually do this we can
add to the size the name length right
this is a little bit annoying because it
means that once we actually set that we
can't easily change it but if we do
something like this it means that every
time we add a field we can simply add on
that size right
and then suddenly now it means that we
never have to loop through anything we
can just return size okay
that's one way of doing it again the
only reason I wouldn't recommend you
doing this is because the size of course
if we do start removing fields we have
to handle that again not oh that's easy
don't know that's hard to do we can just
do minus equals however if we do do set
name that's when we have to kind of make
sure that we actually control this okay
so the way that I'm gonna do it is I'm
actually going to do it this way because
this way is better
so what I'll do is the only fragile part
is this thing here okay so basically
what I should do is I have to keep track
of names like that the easy way to do
this is just to have our one plus two
here because that's always gonna be the
same
not to worry about named at length at
all and then every time we get the size
we can just add on name dot length all
right and that way it's always gonna be
up-to-date if we set the name again we
don't have to worry about it at all the
other thing that we could do if we
really wanted to and this is totally
fine but you could also do something
like size and minus equals this dot name
dot length if so if if this dot name
doesn't equal null which it which it
should be now it will be known at the
beginning then we do that and then at
the end we plus it with the new name or
like written like this for example I'm
sorry this one biggest one name will it
this will be I as at all yeah something
like that right or plus equals name
length that's also acceptable totally
fine you can do it that way as well in
fact that's probably gonna be better
than having to add that all the time
because
because we can actually use the field
here we don't have to use getsize so
there's a few different ways to do it as
you can see that's just a bit of insight
as to what you can choose so name of
course will be null at this point before
we actually do named occupy it's okay
cool so let's kind of leave it at that
and that should work perfectly so we've
added fields we've added arrays now the
big thing and we know the size of
everything with because we keep
calculating that so the last thing we
need to implement now is get bytes so we
have that and what is that other
parameter than 0 of course that's the
pointer so where are we you asked the
object pointer so again this is going to
be pretty much the same as it is in all
the other ones in this case we did that
so it's copy and paste that it's gonna
be a bit different but basically we have
our destination here and we have this as
an int and I'm going to do the it's
gonna be the exact same thing as far as
this goes and then of course instead of
type and data it's just going to be us
printing our fields and stuff so the way
that we the way that we can do that is
just by having a full loop called RC
field so we'll go through each field in
fields and we'll set pointer equal to
right bytes and then of course the
destination pointer and then instead of
type will write field dot yet bytes okay
and again actually we don't even have to
do that do we we don't have to write by
it's because it will write it for us so
if we do feel they'll get by its
destination and pointer sorry and we
have to make sure that we increment that
pointer that should write all that stuff
for us because get bytes will actually
write them into our into the parameter
that we so this really shouldn't be get
byte strategic process or write bytes
because get bytes kind of assumes that
it's going to return a new thing for us
so that's something that we could
definitely change as far as naming goes
all right cool
and then we'll have the same thing for
array and that's actually it okay that's
all we have to do actually no it's not
because I forgot to write out these
sizes that's very important so what we
want to do is we want to write out the
amount of field
we have now remember every field is not
going to be the same size that's very
important to realize same with the race
right we have no idea what the size of
the array is until we actually look at
the array and see what size it is so
again that's not a problem or anything
is just something to keep in mind so
we'll have to do pointer ride bytes
destination pointer and field dot size
all right now this will be a an int
which I'm kind of okay with I don't
really mind very much and then we'll do
the same thing here as well now instead
of doing this this way which is totally
fine I'm actually I actually am going to
add it here I'm going to save and we can
we'll keep this private private private
int yeah what changes to short
private short field count and then after
that we'll have a private short array
count again whether or not you want to
saw that like that or like that it's up
to you the reason is I like having an
actual structure to my like object so
that when I'm deserializing it and when
we have to look at the structure we
actually see what it should be we don't
have to keep referring to get bias which
of course is a bit more complicated so
this should now be printing our field
count and this should now be printing
our array count so of course all we have
to do is every time we add a field we
simply set field count equal to fields
count or rather fuel size of course
instead of that and we'll cost that to a
short of course instead of that we could
be doing something as simple as
incrementing it every time we add a
field but I'd this is just a bit a
little bit better because it means that
if we ever have something like adding an
array of fields straight away we don't
have to like incremented by that amount
or anything like that so I don't know
it's again multiple as I've demonstrated
this episode hopefully there are a
million ways to do this but this is just
the way that I've chosen so we have
field counter
and that should be of course up-to-date
and accurate cool
so there we go and if we don't already
you'll see this will just be set to zero
okay cool so there we have it that
should be everything let's go ahead and
ride this out and see what happens so
I'll hit the debug button Oh we crashed
probably because of object get sized
right so we try to get the bytes and
that did not work how many arrays we
have we have one so let's see what the
problem was how many first of all how
many of these do we have what is the
length of stream let's switch over to
debug we did do object I'll get sighs
yes we did adding arrays and stuff did
increment the size by that hmm oh of
course 900 MS we forgot about these ones
so for the size then I guess we'll
definitely put so name the length is
something that we set here and then we
also need to make sure that we have plus
two plus two for each of these all right
so let's run that and this time it
looked like it worked so there's our
test file 196 kilobytes this is probably
gonna be a little bit difficult to read
I think it reloaded everything again
let's go back up to the top alright and
let's go through this so all we did was
we wrote out a single object yeah that's
that's the only thing that's the only
thing that this stream contains so if we
go into object we the first thing we
should see is the container type of
object so you can see that we have a
byte here that says three which matches
object the next thing we have is a short
which let me just close all this stuff
that we don't need anymore we have we
should have a short which is the name
length so the name length is six
characters then we have the characters
which make up that name which is entity
the thing that we called our RC object
alright straight after that we should
have our field counts how many fields we
should have again a short and we see we
have one field okay and then inside
field of course we know that
that we have an RC field which is which
means it's one right because field is
equal to one and then we have name
lengths we know that up fields work
correctly already so we have the name
length which is seven then we have the
word integer which are these bytes here
right - this one and then we have a byte
for the type 4 which is integer right if
we go into type 4 is integer right over
here and then what we have I guess we've
got the data right so what was 4 4 was
integer and then here's the actual
integer 8 right I wonder if I can zoom
in here I mean I could I'm sure you guys
can see this though so I'm not gonna
bother with that all right so we set
that to 8 of course here it is and then
what we have I think I said right that's
it for field yeah that's it a field
so after that we have the array count
which again is a short which is set to 1
and then we have the beginning of the
array so our array of course means that
our container type is set to array which
is number two and that's the two you see
here and then we have let's see and then
we have the name length of the name so
the name length over here is d which is
13 and then we have the name which is
random numbers you can see it over here
in our viewer I might just make this
like 32 or something just so that we can
kind of see more here that actually kind
of I think I made it harder to read oh
well then we've got the type which is an
integer which should be 4 right there it
is the count so how many things we have
in an array which is an integer so here
it is see 350 that's quite a high number
well we know that it's 50,000 and then
of course we have the actual data which
is what the rest of this file is up
until the very end
ok so there we go that's how we
implement object again the only problem
that we're gonna have is because when we
have all these container type if if we
have a lot of them and we want to find
specific things then we kind of have to
iterate through this tree to figure out
you know how far we need to go right so
for example if I might get past the
first object how do I know how many
bytes that is yeah one of the floors
here that kind of comes up is we don't
know how big the object is right we have
a size but we don't actually print that
out you'll notice we only have in order
to find out how big the object is we
actually need to we don't write that out
anywhere and that's kind of a floor I
think as well that we could definitely
work on you could just write out you
know the integer size uh-hum and you
would be totally fine and really we're
probably gonna start talking about that
and other optimization things a bit
later on but that is the basics of how
we can have all of those container types
implemented okay the last container type
is actually a data base which is
basically the entire file and a data
base which will add right now data base
take up to four that's what we're going
to work on next time and that's going to
have that that is the thing that
contains objects arrays
well that contains objects right and
that is what the actual file that that's
the kind of the highest level that we
can go as far as um the file scope this
is like if field is like field an array
are kind of lowest levels object is kind
of in the middle and data base is the
highest level thing we have which is the
actual file alright guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this episode
please hit the like button and yeah I
mean I don't have much else to say I'll
see you guys next time goodbye